this is what I did for 25 years from 25
to 51 years old spent my most valuable
asset time to get money terrified every
second of every that's really what's
Driven me the whole time was Tara like
when you don't know you're going to be
scared so I'm going out to get money I
won't I won't spend any of it because
I'm terrified if I can't I don't know
how to get more I'm worried I can't keep
getting more so then I'd get the money
and then I'd rush off and spend my most
valuable asset time again to bring it to
the bank they're telling me to save it
and they don't and so when I quit
listening to everybody that's got an
opinion about money online or my
neighbors or my uncles and I started
saying what are they doing when I quit
studying the influencers and started
studying the banks Goldman JP Morgan KKR
there's it's an endless list of these
guys hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because I need them because
I don't always wake up and feel
motivated to go take on the day and the
thing that saves me that helps me every
day is being around people who are
thinking bigger who are change in the
world and it gives me a little more
inspiration to go after my mission and
so I hope this video helps you go up to
yours today too so today let's learn
from some money experts on how to go
from zero to a million enjoy
you start studying those guys Elon study
Elon Elon doesn't keep any cash
he thinks the whole thing's a joke
which is probably right so so what does
he do he reinvests everything
he's not paying debt off he's
accumulating debt but Apple has debt
Google has debt Facebook has debt and
they have cash reserves that that are
the biggest cash reserves on planet
Earth they could pay cash for everything
why they don't why do they get debt when
they have exactly why do they do that
because because if I take if I take man
you got a little white board right here
Manny okay so if I take uh the Apple
just did this okay I got nine I want to
make a 90 billion dollar purchase
and they're like yeah we got the cash
for that in fact we have Cash Plus
another 50 yeah we got plenty of cash to
do this
okay and then one of their people says
okay bro you do that that is not a tax
deductible event
what we should do
is we should go keep this
and go borrow 90 billion really and like
point zero zero five percent
they're gonna pay a half one percent
for this debt maybe they pay one percent
who cares they're like I don't care it's
a tax deduction anyway interesting
so now they have the best of both worlds
they have their cash and they have debt
now back in when I was growing up this
debt would cost 10 12 15 18 it's so
cheap now this is dead because we print
money we money is not scarce like our
parents told us
like when I was growing up I bet you I
heard
I heard at least from my mother from the
age of 10 to 15. if I didn't hear this
500 or a thousand times I never heard it
once we don't own the electric company
turn those Lights Out Boy hmm
still have that going on today
my dad my mom told me my dad would
because he worked so hard dude like he
was so like oh I finally got it I
finally made it now I got to protect it
he got stuck in the second piece keeping
it
you know it's an emotional keep and so
it's not a rational thing because you're
hoarding now
you know still today man it's tough for
me to buy blue jeans if they're not on
sale I'm like this is stupid man like
I'm just gonna wait right you know so
say you know what I'm saying but it's
really stupid that I even worry about it
right
and I'm not saying on the come up I
think you should worry about it right
but there needs to be where you can turn
that switch off rule number two is start
investing with the meat safety investing
does not mean you have to wear a suit
and tie and be looking at 15 screens
with green letters rolling across it's
all okay real investors are not
checking their accounts every day you
know how often I advise people to look
at their investment accounts
once every six months it's boring it's
not a TNT Drama okay you want to have
fun get HBO this is not that investing
is you set it up once you automatically
have money sent from your checking
account every month and it just that's
it that's it and you can actually
mathematically predict exactly when you
will become a millionaire or have 500k
or 5 million so what kind of Investments
are we talking about
um the in my opinion uh the Investments
that I have put most of my net worth
into are simple low-cost index funds let
me tell you what an index fund is most
people think uh you know investing is
like picking stocks no it's not even
Wall Street Professional investors when
they pick stocks they fail to beat an
index fund over 80 percent of the time
so an index fund is basically a
collection of different stocks imagine
those Planters peanuts you get you know
those ones instead of just getting
trying to pick out peanuts you get the
Planters mixed nuts it's got the almonds
and the pecans and all that stuff that's
an in-disc fund it's got a whole bunch
of different stocks in it
um when you invest you do not have to
become an expert in these companies all
the simplest thing you can possibly do
to start investing today is to get
something called a Target date fund now
let me tell you why this is so easy and
how it works let's pretend that you are
I don't know 30 years old let's just say
okay and
that means that we can assume you're
going to retire in 35 years okay so what
you do is you go over to Fidelity or
Vanguard or any of the places that I
talk about in my book and you open up a
Target date fund the target date fund is
going to be like a 2050 fund or whatever
the number is that corresponds to when
you retire all it is is one simple fund
it's like a pie chart
and all you do is just send money in
there every month now when you get this
target date fund again we're talking
about how do I start investing when you
invest in a Target date fund it's low
cost it's really cheap
and all you're doing is picking One Fund
it's automatically Diversified so your
only job is just to put as much money as
you possibly can into it and as you get
a little older it will automatically
become conservative and you can predict
because we know the historical returns
of the market which are about seven or
eight percent per year you can actually
predict when you will become a
millionaire rule number three is use
social media with Cody Sanchez you are
putting a lot of effort into social
media I am putting a lot of effort into
social media why are why are you doing
it what's the point of growing this is
just ego is it you know because there's
probably a little bit that definitely
drives me but like why do you do it I
started it uh in 2020 for a couple
different reasons one was got a little
bored because I wasn't doing Road shows
and private Equity like I was for the
past like 15 years running around every
week you know the deal raising money
from investors vetting deals I was
working like 60 70 80 hour weeks and
when covet happened I had a little bit
of time and I actually got to take a
step back and think for a minute and in
that period I was trying to think about
leverage so basically what is the
highest leverage activity for my time
that I could spend in this moment and
for most of my career I hadn't thought
that way I had really sort of thought
what's the next step in my career and
then the next step but there's a power
play to determining how you want to
spend your time and if you can actually
think okay what is the you know as
Archimedes said give me a fulcrum and a
lever give me a fulcrum and a lever to
place upon it and and if you have a long
enough version you can move the world
right and so I kind of thought about
that with social media and I think I
read a post from Naval ravacon that
basically talked about the three levels
of Leverage which was first employment
or people you know you could do
something bigger than yourself if you
convinced other people to join you and
then the second lever was Capital most
of the big wealthy humans that we know
through time as Titans like the
Rockefellers and the Rothschilds were
created during the Banking Act Right
when we got access to other people's
Capital at scale and then the third was
code Bezos Mas
Gates all of these guys had Early Access
to technology before other people did
and so they had an army of robots quote
unquote online and the fourth one that
he hadn't talked about enough yet was
audience and audience in my mind is the
first permissionless form of Leverage
Banks you had to ask for the money code
you had to have access to the technology
and for humans you needed money to pay
them right
and now we had audience and I thought
wait a second I'm running around trying
to raise capital for investment deals
I'm doing you know I'm in the million
Mile Club I'm doing a hundred thousand
plus miles uh a year
um it's actually not that fun what would
it look like if instead of me going to
people I brought them to me and once I
started looking at the power of social
media I thought oh my this is I can't
believe I haven't seen this before in
finance we don't typically do social
media because unlike real estate we have
way tighter rules for for raising
capital and so um I remember I worked at
a firm where I was had all these
licenses you know 66 and 63 in series 7
and 24 and my firm said you know if you
say anything publicly you could move the
markets I'm like bro it's like me and my
mom on here nobody's following my stuff
yet
um but they basically you know my CEO at
the time said to me we get rich quietly
um you know we we get rich quietly and
we don't talk about it we don't make a
Ruckus and I thought I don't know I
think we could like get rich in public
if we did it the right way and so that
convinced me oh I'm going to build a
huge social audience I'm going to never
do another steak dinner and I'm going to
see how big this could get it turns out
it's I was right also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is operate by the
95.5 rule with Tillman Fertitta operate
by the 95.5 rule 95 of of everything we
do in business if we're doing anything
is right so look for the five percent
uh I didn't find the five percent this
is so powerful and reading it in the
book I was like okay here we go so how
do you spot the five percent how do you
know what five percent matters how do
you prioritize how you attack that five
percent okay well let me just say this
okay I walked into this studio okay and
and I've done a lot of interviews and
and uh as soon as I walk in your your
people greet you they introduce you know
this you come up here here's uh here's
some snacks there's even a a camera
light uh so if they're doing your makeup
up there it's a perfect lighting uh you
I could tell this guy has his act
together this this guy I'm having a hard
time finding his five percent because
they're doing everything right and I'm
not just saying that but you know
everything I'm saying is true that you
have somebody meet us outside we're not
walking around lost and and uh so I
hadn't found the five percent here I'm
sure before the show's over I will but
but it's there for sure I think you're
right everybody has but I judged you you
and your operation the second I walked
in and it's no different if I'm pulling
up to a retail store or a hotel or a
restaurant or whatever and before I get
to the front door I'm pulling up in that
parking lot is the parking lot in pretty
good shape for their weeds out there or
their cigarette butts in the parking lot
uh or their lights burn out uh the front
door's got a bunch of smudges on it I
haven't even walked in yet and I can
tell you this isn't a crisp operation
I can tell you everything how the
operation is going to be inside before I
ever walked in the front door because if
they're not taking care of the outside
the inside's not going to be good rule
number five is learn how to sell with
Robert Kiyosaki a fortunate thing was I
had a rich dad and I learned about money
early and you know so I keep asking
people what does school teach you about
money nothing
right so that's why so many guys aren't
Rich you know but my poor dad was a PhD
in education and no money at all
and I didn't want to follow in his
footsteps so I started off with Rich Dad
Poor Dad
and my rich dad was the one teaching me
how to be a successful like I was
adjusting it at the with Patrick Davis
I wanted to be an entrepreneur
but Rich Dad said to me says you got to
learn how to sell now my poor dad
thought sales under a scum
so I had that going in my head so my
rich dad says learn to sell I can hear
my poor Dad saying was salesmen are scum
they're Crooks they'll tell their liars
and all this stuff that was in my head
oh my God so finally rich dad was saying
to me so I don't like how can I get rich
without selling well sales equals income
as you know so I find somebody who's
poor because they can't sell but a lot
of it's because you have people like my
poor does saying salesman has come you
know what I mean so that's inside your
head already there
so I said to my richest I said but I
don't want to sell
I don't you know I I took real estate
courses that got rich like he advised
and finally my rich dad asked me as I
just said How's your sex life so here
I'm a marine I'm in shape you're what
age at this point well 28 26 27.
you know it feels like in good shape and
all this live in a nice place nice cars
but I so I said but I don't want to sell
he says so rich Ted says to me how's
your sex life
so with that I said I'd better learn how
to sell and so rather than taking I was
going to fly for the airlines because
there's a pilot
I went to work for Xerox because they're
the best sales training so I was flown
from Hawaii to Leesburg Virginia and
learned how to sell and all this
and I realized then is that sales equals
income but in all areas of life you
cannot sell you cannot communicate
cannot Market
toast rule number six is find your
circle of competence of Warren Buffett
how come you haven't bought Amazon is
there still time to buy would you still
buy it oh I I always admired Jeff I mean
I met him 20 years ago or so and and
I thought it was something special but I
didn't realize you could go from books
to it what's happened there no I I mean
he had a vision and executed in an
incredible way something that it would
not have you know that but there's a lot
of games I miss I would have missed you
know I would have missed Microsoft even
if I got into no bill earlier or
something those just aren't my games I
don't worry about the things that I miss
that are outside my circle of competence
of evaluating I I do I have missed
things that were within my circle and
that's a terrible mistake those are my
biggest mistakes you haven't seen them
and but I don't it's not a mistake
because I miss Netscape or something
like that at all I would say that maybe
five percent of the companies or ten
percent of the companies at most are
within an area of my circle of
confidence there's something I should be
able to understand and rule number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips stop wasting money with
Jason if you want to have more money one
way is to uncover the areas where you
may be wasting money and that's why
we're talking about five common ways we
throw money away where exactly did your
money go money is something a lot of us
struggle with check this out in a 20 19
employees survey at PWC 71 of
Millennials said their money stress had
gone up over the past year it is
stressing me out and nearly half of all
respondents said that they spent three
hours or more every week thinking about
or trying to sort out their finances and
money woes don't just affect us
individually 44 of young adults said
that the money is the number one
stressor in their relationship I need to
borrow some money and check out these
stats according to Erin Lowry creator of
the broke Millennial Blog the average
Millennial graduated with 37 000 in
student debt that's in the state and
some have much more that's enough to buy
a brand new car or put a down payment on
a house maybe you're like yeah don't
remind me Jay hey I get it lots of Us
come from tough places financially and
you might be there now growing up my
family definitely was not what you'd
call wealthy for some of us the hard
times actually help spur us on to
success here's one of the stories that's
really inspired me it's of a young man
who at 14 was evicted with his mother
from their apartment and couldn't afford
a place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that's why he named his company seven
bucks Productions still even if you
don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and the place to start is
to stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what I'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment Financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple Financial expert
sus Allman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body okay
never mind you get it anyway Omen says
that if you invested the 100 or more per
month so many of us spend on coffee in a
rough retirement account over 40 years
with compound interest you'd have a
million dollars what that's worth making
your own coffee right actually the
entire category of food and drink is a
big one not only do we spend loads of
money eating out for dinner another big
money waster people often Overlook is
lunch here's a quick quiz how much do
you think the average person spends on
lunch in a year according to Visa is it
a 520 B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends two thousand seven
hundred and forty six dollars per year
on lunches now check this out if instead
of buying lunch you invested that money
every month in a basic savings account
over 20 years you'd have hope you're
sitting down because this is
unbelievable you'd have sixty thousand
seven hundred and sixty dollars and 41
cents I'm gonna sit down and that's just
with basic compounding interest okay so
here's another big way we raise money
buying new now here's the thing I know
for lots of us I'll be honest myself
included how we look is important we
enjoy fashion but you can continue to
have your unique look and have favorite
brands and still spend less money on
clothing here's a way to do that I have
another friend who's into designer
Brands but would never pay designer
prices her secret is to shop at
consignment stores and now that there
are lots of these stores online there
are tons of items to choose from and you
can even shop by your favorite Brands
the other month I complimented my friend
on a sweater and she told me she got it
for 65 less than the original price and
it came brand new with the tag still
attached plus shopping Consignment also
benefits the environment because we're
recirculating clothes instead of just
making more stuff Beyond clothing there
are loads of things we tend to buy brand
new that we really don't need to
at some point you have to decide whose
life you're living are you living your
version of your life or you're living
your parents version of your life or
your friend's version of your life or
your community's version of your life or
society's version of your life so
everybody has a goal for you right
everybody has an idea of what you should
do with your life everybody's an opinion
on how you should be who you should
marry what job you should take on how
many kids you should have you know what
what profession to get into what country
to live in everybody's got an opinion on
what you should do with your life and
when you are not sending on a rock solid
foundation what ends up happening is you
get pulled in a million different
directions like there is no way that
you're going to make everybody happy
there's no way because there's different
competing opinions
and so if you're trying to make this
this group happy and then that group
happened and this group happened that
group happy you end up making nobody
happy and worst of all you're not happy
biggest problem is all of all is that
you're not happy
I had somebody message me on Instagram
the other day
saying that
they want to chase down their
aspirational dreams be an entrepreneur
but their parents won't let them
okay
well at some point you have to decide
when are you living your life
and when you live in your parents
version of your life
and what that requires is you
getting off the payroll
right
if you want to live your life but you're
living under their roof that's a problem
right
when do you stand up for yourself and
maybe if you're 13 years old that's
that's too young maybe you can't do it
maybe that's not possible Right but is
it at 16 is it at 18 is it a 20 is it at
24 is that 32 is it at 46 like it's
people in their 50s still living the
life that their parents want for them
instead of that they want for them or
again their Community their partner or
the people around them Society you're
not living your version of your life
and so how do we fix it how do you gain
the courage how do you gain the strength
how do you get the momentum maybe a
couple strategies that I hope will help
number one is to figure out Yahoo but
you're saying the most important core
value I wrote a book uh called your one
word and another one called built to
serve in the first exercise that I got
people through is to figure out what is
your single most important core value
what do you stand for as a human
you know and you can read the books to
dive in deeper but if you just
thought about he spent two seconds and
thought about it close your eyes and ask
yourself what is my single most
important core value as a human
what is it
and then from there
you gain
a new sense of strength and courage
because mine is belief right so if you
look at mine believe well I need to then
do things that are in accordance with
belief whenever I'm not happy whenever
I'm not
a bold whenever I'm feeling down is
because there's a lack of belief
somewhere in my life
because I want to be doing something but
I'm not I don't believe in myself or I
don't believe in the thing that I'm
doing
it adds a level of clarity that I didn't
have before
so what's yours what's your single most
important core value you know what do
you stand for as a human and don't worry
about it being perfect but if you're not
happy right now if your most important
core value is freedom and you are
feeling trapped under somebody else's
rules you're not gonna be happy you know
why because your most core value is
freedom
right it says to make sense
so identify what you're what that core
value is because it'll help you make
better decisions it gives you the rock
to stand on instead of standing on
quicksand if you're being pulled in a
million different directions by other
people and their agenda for your time is
because you do not have that rock you
know something is wrong you know you're
sinking but you don't know why and you
don't know how to stand strong this is
it your single most important core value
figure out your who that's step number
one
step number two is once you figure out
your who
we need to start to limit access or cut
out the things that make us feel against
that so if my who is believe then
anything that makes me feel a lack of
belief I want to stop spending time with
I want to unsubscribe from the channels
that make me feel less than I want to
stop spending time with friends who pull
me down I want to
dedicate myself to
not being around the negativity
you know think about the last time you
scroll through Instagram or you're
scrolling through YouTube how many of
the videos and pieces of content that
you watch make you feel better about
yourself right like did it make you feel
better about yourself or Worse about
yourself
important question
thank you to make you feel better about
yourself or Worse about yourself
and if it's worse about yourself if you
just found yourself schooling for 40
minutes through Instagram and now you
feel like a loser it's not Instagram's
problem
it's not the platform's fault it's the
people that you're following
stop following the people who make you
feel worse about yourself how do you
know well you have an audit right now
that you know you're saying the most
important core value you have a gauge so
for me does this person that I'm
subscribed to are following make me feel
more or less believe cool that becomes
an easy decision what to do next right
then you go to the people in your life
your friends your family through these
people make me feel more or less believe
for me right insert your word for you
cool less stop spending time with them
maybe maybe completely cut off access or
if it's you know your parents or
somebody really close to you then put up
walls over the things that you will talk
about
limit access you may not go to the
extreme of completely cutting the person
out of your life but at least limiting
access so that
that you don't wake up every day and
feel
terrible
right I think that stuff matters so step
number one is we're gonna figure out our
most important core value what's your
hoop right so number two is then we're
going to restrict access or cut off the
people the things that we're feeding
into our mind that make us feel worse
about ourselves and then three is we
need to inject new great things into our
lives we need to inject new positive
amazing people into our lives right
people who make you feel your core value
belief for me right so I want to I make
my videos still for myself
the videos on my Channel I want to watch
for myself and thankfully you guys like
it enough that I can turn it into a
business bring on an amazing team and
help go off and Inspire even more people
but it's a conscious choice
you know most of us wake up like an
accident and fall into our day and it's
time to make a conscious choice to shift
that to say no instead what I'm going to
do is I'm going to be really intentional
with who I'm spending my time with what
I'm feeding into my mind
because that'll make a giant difference
in how you show up if you're constantly
around negativity distraction
pessimism it's not that you can't show
up and be great it's just you're making
things a thousand times harder for
yourself versus and you know you felt
that when you're around the people are
you're in the environment where you feel
bold and Powerful Unstoppable and you
can do anything guess what you go off
and you start doing amazing things you
never thought you were capable of
and so that's the key difference
you have to protect your dream
you have to realize that everybody has
that
dream for you and it's not really for
you it's mostly for them
right it's like they gave up on their
dreams they never chase down their goals
and so now they're putting all their
hopes on you they want you to go live
the life that they never had
but that's not a fair
dirt in the carry because you don't want
their life you don't want the same
things that they want that's not what
you want to do
and so if you can go through that
process
and recognize that yes you have Michael
Jordan a level genius at something right
you have Michael Jordan level genius at
something
you can be great
and it's probably not doing the thing
that your parents wanted you to do or
your family or Community what you grew
up learning in school it's probably
something completely different
and when you can figure out your most
important core value when you can
completely eliminate or cut off access
to the people the things that bring you
down and we can inject the positivity
into your life on a daily basis on a
consistent basis it'll change everything
everything
time to get to work one of the things
that will help you to do the work to
create the things that you want in your
life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool date let's
go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every
single freaking day of your life you
could if you train your mind and if you
start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going
to talk about
so for those of you that have read the
high five habit one of the things that I
talk about a lot is every single day
find a naturally occurring heart-shaped
object in the world it could be a stone
it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey
Chris if we've got anything around here
that looks like a heart hand it to me
and the reason why I love telling you to
start playing a game with yourself well
you start your day going mind brain show
me some heart oh what is this come here
dog treat oh my God it's a dog treat
look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen and if you
tell yourself something amazing is going
to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will
something will if you want to see the
good all around you you got to tell your
mind you want to see the good and this
just isn't a bunch of horsesh everybody
this isn't toxic positivity there is a
filter in your brain called the
reticular activating system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give a sh about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there I don't know how many
of you have read dostoevsky's crime and
punishment but I would highly recommend
that in crime and punishment the
protagonist commits the perfect murder
and he has his reasons for it and many
reasons because Dostoevsky didn't mess
around when he wanted to give someone
reasons he gave them reasons and
raskolnikov that main character had
reasons for murder and then he commits
his murder and he gets away with it
but things don't go well for skolnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the riskalnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the riskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill I guess right
it's like it that's the Matrix correct
the red pill
and once there's certain actions once
you take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and raskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's a great book it's truly a
great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you human consciousness is that
faculty that confronts potential itself
I think there's good neurological
evidence for this by the way for those
of you who are scientifically minded
because
we build
circuits within us for habitual action
that we've practiced many times that
seem to run in a very deterministic
fashion and we are a strange combination
of deterministic and non-deterministic
as far as I can tell but what our
Consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered and those things that we
have not yet encountered seem to me to
be those things that have not yet been
brought into being and so you could say
that what our Consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our Consciousness is for the
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and and really that that's what
our Consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be you have some
apprehension about what role your
choices might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another I mean you certainly know that
there are Dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that likely
things would at least not be worth and
they would probably be better and I I I
believe that I do believe that I don't
understand how this can be the case I
don't understand how it is that
Consciousness Consciousness can function
in that way because I think to
understand that we would have to
understand what it means for the future
to be only potential rather than
actuality and who the hell understands
that I mean no one and then we'd have to
understand how it is that our conscious
choices and our conscious ethical
choices transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again I
would say that's a very deep idea I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
the most true idea I know it's very
emphasize that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in Genesis or in
Genesis with its strange insistence that
you know God is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image is to act in
relationship to the potential that
confronts you with truth and with
courage with careful articulation that's
the logos and that if you do that then
what you bring forth is is good when it
comes to an affirmation affirmations can
be powerful uh
and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80
000 thoughts per day some of those
thoughts are the words to the songs and
they are the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that creates stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift at the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I say I'm about a
million times a day I said do they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times that we have
lost our power and that we have no
ability to communicate with a greater
power with god with the forces around us
uh and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship the fundamental physics of
our relationship to our world uh have
been minced and parceled and in many
cases deleted from the texts leaving us
with a sense that we are essentially
powerless beings and if you are
powerless then you are a victim and if
you are a victim you need a savior and
that savior is coming to us on a silver
plate in terms of technology in terms of
political leaders I will save you if you
just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies in the earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
it's for me it's it's a uh it's good
news it's a beautiful message of Hope
and possibility uh as a sovereign
biological being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor is it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in I was at the CERN superconducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen it's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you
you are becoming the change so you're
becoming the abundance you're becoming
uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
[Music]
little and it's powerful it's not making
something happen out there and that
means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community as to whether or not I would
allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right we're on good or bad but we
have a choice to make another path
and when we begin as a scientist
beginning to understand these
relationships gave me the reason to
think differently
and it also gave me the reason to test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't I know you
all have big goals Big Dreams big
aspirations just like I do you've got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create contribute
to give to be an awesome human being but
all of that is impossible without great
habits set up if you don't have routine
and structure set up in a way that will
keep you on track then you'll fall off
and and having new goals without new
habits is kind of like you know having a
new car without wheels you know the
habits are the wheels they're the things
that make you able to achieve the goals
so you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do I mean by that well let's say
you want to become a better person you
know you want to become more kind more
patient more loving with people now you
can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision in your journal
or set up on a vision board that you
look at once in a while but in
day-to-day life it's not enough you need
things to trigger you to remind you to
be that particular kind of person right
it's almost like if you could have a
little angel speaking in your ear all
day long to tell you what to do and how
to be you'd obviously become better well
that makes sense well let's use that
idea let's use that idea by setting up
alarms on our phones that trigger us to
do the very things we need to do this
can be so basic you're going to laugh
and then also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you can meditate in the
morning say today don't be more present
and calm and you're you could you could
start out with good intentions but those
fall apart without a trigger moment set
up throughout the day to remind you that
so what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said
close your eyes
[Music]
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
p.m and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right this could be as simple as
let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water put
your exercise shoes on uh might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was how people
described you what would those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life I teach Executives to do this as
well I have them have a door frame
trigger when they walk into their office
in the morning as soon as they walk
through that door frame they have boom
three words go through their mind about
how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be
so these are Big crazy things a lot of
people think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you uh have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn the billionaire habits
that can make you wealthy check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there well in terms of a
day-to-day habit I think uh being
curious I've been curious about the
world how the world works and curious
about technology and we're curious about
everything really I think curiosity is a
very important thing to have and then